I'd like to know when my beauty ended for you
this is one of the most powerful statements I have ever heard on this app
Doctor Zoe I have a PhD in feminist consciousness raising
and I wanna talk about it
because it's about when the male fantasy of you drops away
are you treated differently when he sees you as a person
as a person as a human or less than when the fantasy drops
we've all experienced it to some degree
does he treat you differently
you are feminist
and what I mean by that is
is your conscience feminist
has your feminist consciousness been raped
well our feminist consciousness is raised with me
notice a gap there is a gap between our humanity and reality
a nice man will tell you that he has a wife and he has a daughter
and he was raised by a single mother and he respects women
but that is not what he means when he says that
he means I respect the women in my life who give me love
affection and attention I respect the women in my life who I can protect
I respect the women in my life who I see value in
I respect those women I don't respect women
we've all gone from being one of those women to being
a woman who he doesn't respect anymore because we're not behaving
because we're using in a a body in a way that he doesn't agree with
because we're too loud or too opinionated
because we're no longer a woman who he sees value in or who he can control
then we notice the gap and what happens when we notice the gap
feminist consciousness is raised
we get angry
and you know what what happens when women get angry
we are propelled by kind of a productive feminist rage
and feminist rage is contagious
feminist rage is contagious because
we start talking
we start acting differently
acting how we want
using our opinions using our voice
like this creator is describing in her video
when we start doing that
the gap widens because we're no longer acting
playing the part that men expect of us
so more men begin to disrespect us
the truth
is peeled back and then we talk more
we get more angry and other women see that
and then other women start noticing the gap
and then they start talking and they start acting up
and they start being who they wanna be
not playing the part ascribed
and then they notice the gap
because then they notice what it is
how they're treated when they're seen as a bad woman
back up then widens for them
then they start talking feminist rage is contagious
feminist consciousness propels the movement
it is not an individual process
it is a collective process
it's a process about solidarity with one another
being a feminist is a becoming
it is a constant becoming
it is a collective process
a constant collective process of becoming
of raising consciousness in ourself and then in others
so that's why I ask are you a feminist